This bonus episode of 99% Invisible is brought to you by Get Your Guide. So you booked your flights, you booked your accommodations, but why wait for your adventure to start when you arrive at your destination? Anticipation is part of the adventure. With Get Your Guide, planning becomes an experience in itself. Feed your excitement by digging into their wide range of experiences and offerings. Choose from over 150,000 experiences, including guided tours, sightseeing excursions, adventure activities, museum tickets, and more. With flexible booking options, mobile tickets, and millions of verified reviews,
《99% Invisible》的这期特别赞助节目由 Get Your Guide 提供支持。你预订了航班，预订了住宿，但为什么非要等到抵达目的地才开始冒险呢？期待本身就是冒险的一部分。有了 Get Your Guide，规划行程本身就变成了一种体验。深入了解他们丰富多样的体验和项目，尽情释放你的热情。从 15,000 多种体验中进行选择，包括导游讲解团、观光游览、探险活动、博物馆门票等。凭借灵活的预订选项、手机电子票以及数百万条真实评价，
including one right here, because I've used them in Italy and Spain and San Francisco, and loved every single one I've done, you'll find everything you need to simplify trip planning and book the best things to do in thousands of destinations worldwide. Whether it's an architectural walking tour, hey now, or a behind the scenes museum, Get Your Guide provides in-depth experiences
其中就包括我留下的真实评价，因为我在意大利、西班牙和旧金山都使用过他们家的服务，而且对每一次体验都爱不释手，你将找到简化行程规划所需的一切，并在全球数千个目的地预订最佳玩乐项目。无论是建筑步行之旅（哇哦），还是幕后博物馆参观，Get Your Guide 都能提供深度体验，
that will help you engage in the world in a more meaningful way. And you'll meet cool people in the process. Discover and book experiences for your next trip at GetYourGuide.com. That's GetYourGuide.com. Now, let's get out on the street and tell some stories. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars in San Francisco.
帮助你以更有意义的方式融入这个世界。在这个过程中，你还会结识很酷的人。访问 GetYourGuide.com，发现并预订你下一趟旅程的体验。网址是 GetYourGuide.com。现在，让我们走上街头，讲讲故事。这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars），在旧金山为您主持。
Since Get Your Guide offers adventures and tours all around the world, we decided we would release a bonus episode with our own guide to my favorite stories about San Francisco, the city in my backyard. But you don't have to be walking around with me to experience it. You can join me just by listening. I'd like to start with the most famous building in the city of San Francisco, even though it's no longer the lone tower dominating the skyline. And that is the Transamerica Pyramid, designed by LA architect William Pereira. It's about 850 feet tall, it's a skinny four-sided pyramid with two wings poking out, they look like ears to me, and those wings accommodate the elevator shaft on one side and a stairwell on the other.
由于 Get Your Guide 提供遍布全球的探险和旅行团，我们决定推出一期特别节目，带着我们自己的“指南”，去探索我最喜欢的关于旧金山的故事——这座我后院里的城市。但你不需要亲自和我一起散步也能体验这一切。只需静静聆听，你就能与我同行。我想从旧金山市最著名的建筑开始说起，尽管它已经不再是统治天际线的唯一高塔了。这就是由洛杉矶建筑师威廉·佩雷拉（William Pereira）设计的泛美金字塔（Transamerica Pyramid）。它高约 850 英尺，是一个纤细的四面金字塔，两侧有两个突出的翼楼，在我看来它们长得像耳朵，这些翼楼一边容纳了电梯井，另一边则是楼梯间。
The best view of it is where I'm standing, looking down Columbus Avenue. The building was commissioned by the Transamerica Company. Construction started in 1969. And it was to serve as their headquarters as well as their logo, which strikes me as quite novel and forward thinking. The funny thing is, it's no longer Transamerica's headquarters. They moved to Baltimore some time ago. But it is still their logo. They did a brand refresh in 2025 and the building is depicted in red right next to the word Transamerica. The logo looks great, but they do not own the building anymore. So the idea of making a building a headquarters and a company logo at the same time turned out to be kind of genius. But it was also at the root of why people hated this building so much when it was proposed and first constructed. Many local architects considered it a silly advertising symbol more than a rational
看它的最佳角度就是我现在站的地方，顺着哥伦布大道（Columbus Avenue）望过去。这座建筑是由泛美公司委托建造的。建设始于 1969 年。它既作为他们的总部，也作为他们的公司标志，这在我看来相当新颖且具有前瞻性。有趣的是，这里已经不再是泛美公司的总部了。他们不久前搬到了巴尔的摩。但它依然是他们的公司标志。他们在 2025 年更新了品牌形象，泛美字样旁边描绘的就是红色的这座建筑。这个标志看起来很棒，但他们已经不再拥有这座建筑了。因此，把一座建筑同时用作总部和公司标志的想法，结果证明简直是个天才之举。但这也是为什么当它被提议并初次建造时，人们会如此讨厌它的根本原因。许多当地建筑师认为它更像是一个愚蠢的广告符号，而不是一个理性的
modern building. They were offended that a company would erect an 850 foot logo in the rather diminutive San Francisco skyline. Also, it went up at a time when modernism was at its most influential. When buildings were supposed to be free of unnecessary adornment and just be good functional buildings. Well, to make a pyramid come to a point at the top, it has to have a bunch of empty, non-functional space. The top 200 feet are just air. There are no offices up there. Modernism declared that unethical and even immoral.
现代建筑。他们被一家公司竟然在相对矮小的旧金山天际线上树立一个 850 英尺高的巨型标志这一举动冒犯了。此外，它的兴建正值现代主义最具影响力的时期。当时人们认为建筑应该没有不必要的装饰，只做好实用的建筑就行。然而，要想让金字塔顶部收拢于一个尖顶，它就必须包含大量空置的、无实际功能的空间。顶部 200 英尺纯粹只是空气。上面没有办公室。现代主义宣告这是不道德的，甚至是邪恶的。
Non-architects hated it too. The design took up a whole city block in a part of the city without any other tall buildings. So here are some of the most vicious quotes from the people at the time that I've collected. Putting it in San Francisco would be no less reprehensible than destroying the Grand Canyon. An inhuman creation. A second class world's fair space needle. Then Assemblyman John Burton said that the pyramid would rape the skyline. Which like yowz. I mean this was before Twitter.
非建筑师也同样讨厌它。在旧金山一个没有任何其他高层建筑的区域，这个设计占据了整整一个街区。因此，我收集了当时人们的一些最恶毒的言论：把它放在旧金山，其罪过不亚于毁掉大峡谷。一个非人类的创造。一个二流的世界博览会太空针塔。当时的州议员约翰·伯顿（John Burton）甚至说，这座金字塔将强奸这座城市的天际线。这话真是……我的意思是，这可是发推特之前的年代。
Like, he had to say that as a human to another human. To critics and community members, it seemed to violate the whole purpose of zoning and urban planning. The surrounding buildings were no more than three stories tall. But over the course of 50 years, something happened. Some people have never lost their hatred for the pyramid, but I would classify them as
也就是说，他必须作为一个人当面去对另一个人说这种话。对批评者和社区成员来说，它似乎违背了分区和城市规划的全部意义。周围的建筑最高也不过三层楼。但在过去的 50 年里，事情发生了变化。有些人从未停止对金字塔的厌恶，但我会将他们归类为
a very small minority at this point. The San Francisco chapter of the American Institute of Architects opposed its construction in 1969, but a couple decades later they hailed it as one of the city's best buildings. I interviewed the late San Francisco architect, Henrik Bull, about it about 15 years ago, and he was an early vociferous hater, but he grew to love the pyramid. He was the one who made me appreciate it even more.
目前极少数的人。美国建筑师学会旧金山分会在 1969 年曾反对它的建设，但在几十年后，他们将其誉为该市最好的建筑之一。大约 15 年前，我曾就此采访过已故的旧金山建筑师亨利·布尔（Henrik Bull），他曾经是个激进而直言不讳的反对者，但后来他逐渐爱上了这座金字塔。正是他让我对这座建筑有了更深的欣赏。
He told me that the true beauty of the Transamerica pyramid reveals itself depending on where you're standing. And that is why I'm talking to you on the median in the middle of the street, looking at the pyramid down Columbus Avenue, which is a long, broad diagonal street that cuts through North Beach. The Transamerica Building is right at the end of the street.
他告诉我，泛美金字塔真正的美，会根据你站立的位置而显现出来。这就是为什么我要站在街道中间的安全岛上，顺着穿过北海滩（North Beach）的长而宽的斜街——哥伦布大道，遥望金字塔，跟你说话的原因。泛美大厦就坐落在街道的尽头。
It's at the terminus. And it creates this awesome vanishing point perspective where everything goes in diagonals to a point. And in a way, if you tilt that vanishing point up vertically, there's the Transamerica building. It is this delightful triangular surprise. It perfectly completes the scene. Had that been a conventional modern rectangular building that was popular at the time, it would have been a tragedy according to Henrik Bull and to me.
它位于终点处。并且它创造了一种绝妙的消失点透视效果，所有的线条都以对角线汇聚到一个点上。某种程度上，如果你把那个消失点垂直向上倾斜，泛美大厦就在那里。这是一个令人愉悦的三角形惊喜。它完美地完成了整个场景。亨利·布尔和我一致认为，如果当时盖的是一座当时流行的传统现代矩形建筑，那将是一场悲剧。
It also looks great from the bay as a silhouette when the sun's going down. It's really quite graceful. The taller buildings that have gone up since then are really pretty dull. I don't think of San Francisco as a good skyscraper city. You could say a lot of things about the pyramid, but it is not dull. So I have to thank Henrik Bull for teaching me how to love this weird building that epitomizes San Francisco and looks like a dunce cap. If we go south of here, towards the financial district, you will experience one of my favorite things about San Francisco. The Popos. Popos are privately owned public spaces. Publicly accessible plazas, terraces, atriums, little parks, and even rooftop parks that
从海湾望过去，当夕阳西下时，它作为剪影也显得美极了。它确实相当优雅。自那以后建成的更高大楼宇其实都相当沉闷。我不认为旧金山是一个优秀的高层建筑城市。关于这座金字塔你可以说很多，但它绝对不沉闷。所以我必须感谢亨利·布尔，是他教会了我如何去爱这座代表了旧金山、且长得像个笨蛋帽子的奇怪建筑。如果我们从这里向南走，走向金融区，你将体验到我最喜欢的旧金山特色之一：Popos。Popos 是指私人拥有的公共空间（Privately Owned Public Spaces）。这些是
are provided and maintained by private developers but available for the public to use. They're marked by a handsome sign with the public open space logo which displays the hours that people can access the area. The 1985 downtown plan requires all projects involving new building or the addition of 25,000 square feet or more in the downtown and nearby neighborhoods provide public accessible art equal to at least 1% of the total construction cost. And I love this idea. I think it represents the best of San Francisco.
由私人开发商提供和维护，但供公众使用的公共可达广场、露台、中庭、小公园甚至屋顶公园。它们有醒目的标志，上面带有公共开放空间徽标，并显示了人们可以进入该区域的时间。1985 年的市中心规划要求，在市中心及附近社区涉及新建建筑或增加 25,000 平方英尺或以上面积的所有项目，都必须提供占总建设成本至少 1% 的公共可用艺术品。我非常喜欢这个想法。我认为它代表了旧金山的精髓。
It also exemplifies the city's deeply held but conflicting convictions. Popos are sincerely meant for the public good. I know that and I believe that. But because it is not actually public, no one's quite sure what's allowed inside of a Popo, who's in charge, what the codes of behavior should be. There are security guards, there's hours of operations, there's constant surveillance. Some popos contain priceless works of art. And just because they're publicly accessible, that doesn't mean they're easy to find. The signs do help, but online guides are crucial if you want to find them all. And this is why they'll never supplant the need for truly public spaces. And there's nothing like a well-designed outdoor space.
它也体现了这座城市根深蒂固却又相互冲突的信念。Popos 真诚地旨在造福公众。我知道这一点，我也相信这一点。但由于它实际上并不是公共财产，没有人确切知道在 Popo 里面允许做什么、谁负责、行为准则应该是什么。这里有保安人员、营业时间，还有持续的监控。有些 Popo 包含无价的艺术品。而且仅仅因为它们是公众可以进入的，并不意味着它们很容易找到。标志确实有帮助，但如果你想找到它们全部，在线指南至关重要。这就是为什么它们永远无法取代对真正公共空间的需求。没有什么能比得上一个设计良好的户外空间。
In downtown San Francisco, different plazas will be right across the street from one another, and one will be teeming with people, and the other one will be completely empty. It's a stunning thing to witness, and it doesn't have to do with just the beauty of the place. San Francisco has many beautiful underused parks. It's a stunning thing to witness and it doesn't have to do with just the beauty of the place. San Francisco has many beautiful underused parks. It all comes down to functional design. This was a big part of the Get Your Guide tour that my wife Joy and my stepdaughter Maya and I took in San Francisco, which was fantastic by the way.
在旧金山市中心，不同的广场可能会在街对面遥遥相对，一个会挤满人群，而另一个则空无一人。这是一个令人惊叹的景象，而且这不仅仅与这个地方的美丽有关。旧金山有许多美丽但未得到充分利用的公园。这是一个令人惊叹的景象，而且这不仅仅与这个地方的美丽有关。旧金山有许多美丽但未得到充分利用的公园。这一切都归结于功能性设计。这是我和妻子乔伊（Joy）、继女玛雅（Maya）在旧金山参加的 Get Your Guide 旅行团的重要组成部分，顺便说一句，那次旅行棒极了。
With architecture tours, I'm always a little worried that they're going to devolve into a list of famous names and architectural movements, but our tour guide, Jamie Lasher, had great observations about the architecture, fun stories to tell, and he offered crucial insights into why some public spaces work and some don't. So I was into Jamie's vibe from the get-go, but he truly won my heart when we hung out in the Popo at 525 Market Street, which is one of the most successful Popos in the area. And to explain to me why it was so successful, Jamie referenced urban sociologist William White. Maybe you haven't done an episode on it, but I'm sure you're familiar with William White. After photographing and filming people using public spaces in New York for many, many years,
对于建筑导览，我总是有点担心它们会沦落为一长串名人名姓和建筑流派的枯燥罗列，但我们的导游杰米·拉舍（Jamie Lasher）对建筑有着极佳的观察力，讲的故事也妙趣横生，并且他对为什么有些公共空间行之有效而有些则不然，提供了至关重要的深刻见解。所以从一开始我就很对杰米的频率，但当我们坐在市场街 525 号（525 Market Street）的 Popo 闲逛时，他彻底赢得了我的心，那是该地区最成功的 Popo 之一。为了向我解释它为什么如此成功，杰米提到了城市社会学家威廉·怀特（William White）。也许你没有做过关于他的单期节目，但我确信你对威廉·怀特并不陌生。在纽约拍摄了多年人们使用公共空间的影像后，
he concluded there were four things that made them most successful. Sunlight, seating, and particularly seating, you can move around. Proximity to food and being able to people watch. And this has all four. We've got some bench seating in the back. You've got stadium seating up to this little plaza. If you don't like sitting here close to the street, you can climb up a set of stairs to that kind of mezzanine plaza a little bit above the street with a little different view. Canada is oriented to give a lot of sunshine and it's big enough that there's a nice gap here between the buildings, so a terrific place.
他总结出让公共空间取得最大成功的四个要素：阳光、座椅（尤其是那种你可以随意移动的座椅）、靠近食物来源，以及能够观察来往行人。而这里具备了全部这四点。我们在后面有一些长椅座位。这里还有通往这个小广场的阶梯座椅。如果你不喜欢坐在靠近街道的这里，你可以爬上一组楼梯，到达那个略高于街道、有着略微不同视野的中层夹层广场。这里朝向很好，能获得充足的阳光，而且面积够大，建筑物之间留出了很好的间隙，所以这是一个绝佳的场所。
Sure enough, if you walk around San Francisco or really any city, you will see over and over that a good functional public space probably contains those four things. Movable seating, food, sunlight, and fascinating people to watch. So the current tallest building in San Francisco is Salesforce Tower. And I don't really think all that highly of it. It's this big heavy looking building that I think it's quite a lot better when you get really close to it, but it is not a great addition to the skyline despite its sweaty efforts to stand out. Like the crown of it is lit up at night with 11,000 LED lights. It usually displays a kind of low-res kaleidoscopic
果不其然，如果你在旧金山或任何城市四处走走，你会一次又一次地看到，一个功能良好的公共空间可能都包含这四个要素：可移动的座椅、食物、阳光，以及引人入胜的观赏人群。所以目前旧金山最高的大楼是 Salesforce 大厦（Salesforce Tower）。我对它的评价其实并不高。这是一座看起来很大很沉重的大楼，我觉得当你真正靠近它时，观感要好得多，但尽管它费尽心机想要脱颖而出，它对天际线来说并不是一个很好的补充。比如它的塔顶在夜晚会被 11,000 盏 LED 灯点亮。它通常会显示一种低分辨率的万花筒般
swirl of colors that is generated from cameras placed around San Francisco that, to quote the building's website, monitors the rhythms of the tide and wind, the patterns of the weather, the migration of birds, and the daily ebbs and flows of activity to sort of create its collage. Me explaining that is more interesting than it actually looks, unfortunately. What Salesforce Tower does have going for it is a pretty phenomenal rooftop park located four stories off of street level. If there's a spectrum of popos where on one end is a true public park and the other end is like a museum. The Salesforce park is very much
旋转色彩，这些色彩是由放置在旧金山各处的摄像头生成的，用该大厦网站的话说，它“监测潮汐和风的韵律、天气的模式、鸟类的迁徙，以及日常活动的涨落”，以此来创作它的拼贴画。不幸的是，我对此的解释比它实际看起来要有趣得多。Salesforce 大厦的优势在于它有一个相当惊艳的屋顶公园，位于高出街面四层的高度。如果说存在一个 Popo 的光谱，一端是真正的公园，另一端就像是一个博物馆，
on the museum side of the scale. If you're lucky enough, the gondola is working and you can like ascend into the park on a gondola ride. It often is not and you have to take an elevator. But as soon as you get into the park, you're confronted with a list of activities that you cannot do. Like it doesn't scream fun
那么 Salesforce 公园非常偏向
It's like entering a like your grandma's house Don't touch anything, but the botanical gardens and the plant collections are just out of this world They're so beautiful and it's really nice to be there and it's a great place to take in all the other tall buildings in the neighborhood including what is probably the most infamous San Francisco skyscraper, the Millennium Tower. But our Get Your Guide tour guide, Jamie, had another name for it. We gotta talk about the Leaning Tower of San Francisco, which is the other tall building we can see here.
光谱中博物馆的那一端。如果你够幸运的话，缆车正在运行，你可以像坐缆车一样升入公园。但通常情况并非如此，你必须乘电梯。然而，一旦你进入公园，扑面而来的便是一系列你不能做的事情的清单。这可一点也不让人觉得好玩。
This was really unfortunate for the developer, Millennium Partners, who has done a ton of really amazing high-end, high-rise residential in different places around the country, a lot of it in conjunction with high-end hotel brands like Ritz-Carlton and Four Seasons. They put their name on this one and they just chose the wrong one. So it's across the street from the Salesforce Tower and when it was built, it was the tallest residential tower ever built in San Francisco and the condos were the most expensive ever sold up to that point and
这就像是走进你奶奶的家：什么都别碰。不过这里的植物园和植物收藏简直是绝了。它们太美了，待在那里感觉真的很棒，而且这里是个极佳的观赏地点，能将邻近的所有其他高层建筑尽收眼底，包括可能是旧金山最声名狼藉的摩天大楼——千禧大厦（Millennium Tower）。但我们的 Get Your Guide 导游杰米对它有另一个称呼。我们得聊聊旧金山的斜塔，这是我们在这里能看到的另一座高楼。
you know hasn't worked out so well for the buyers so the foundation here is a little different than many of the others in the neighborhood as you know much of downtown here where it is landfill where Where we're standing was originally a bay and the Gold Rush completely re-engineered the waterfront of San Francisco. There's very very little of the original shoreline of San Francisco along the bay. So we've got sand and bay mud under our feet. There were sand dunes all over that was used as fill material and below that mud that came from sedimentation in the bay. And it goes down a long way.
这对于开发商千禧合伙公司（Millennium Partners）来说真的很不幸，他们在全国各地开发了大量非常高端的高层住宅，其中许多都与丽思卡尔顿（Ritz-Carlton）和四季酒店（Four Seasons）等高端酒店品牌合作。他们在这一座楼上挂出了自己的名字，却偏偏选错了地方。它位于 Salesforce 大厦的街对面，建造时它是旧金山建成的最高住宅塔楼，那里的公寓也是当时售出的最昂贵的公寓，并且
Actually the Salesforce Tower has the deepest foundation ever constructed in San Francisco. It goes down almost 300 feet. Not every building around here goes that deep though. Not everyone goes all the way down to bedrock. There are a number of buildings that have been built that have a big concrete platform that's well underground. You know, it's like a huge, big square of concrete, and all the piers that go up and attach to the building are anchored on that plate.
你知道的，这对买家来说结果并不太妙。这里的地基与邻近地区的许多其他地基有些不同。如你所知，这里的市中心大部分是垃圾填埋地。我们现在站立的地方原本是一个海湾，淘金热彻底重塑了旧金山的海岸线。沿着海湾，旧金山最初的海岸线已经所剩无几。所以我们的脚下是沙子和海湾淤泥。到处都是沙丘，这些沙丘被用作填方材料，在沙丘下方则是海湾沉积作用形成的淤泥。而且这层淤泥向下延伸了很深。
If you make the plate big enough and you put it deep enough, you might get a little bit of compaction. You might have the building settle and sink a little bit, but not too much. There are many buildings around here that have used that. My audio got a little inaudible for a second here but what you missed was Jamie saying that the Millennium Tower had one of these concrete matte foundations. Their structural engineers estimated that worst case it would sink about two inches.
实际上，Salesforce 大厦拥有旧金山建造过的最深的地基。它向下延伸了近 300 英尺。不过，这里的每座建筑并没有都挖得那么深。并不是所有人都会一直打桩到基岩。有相当一部分建筑采用的是地下的大型混凝土平台。你知道的，就像是一个巨大的方形混凝土块，所有向上延伸并与建筑连接的桩柱都锚固在这个底板上。
Right now we're at 18 and climbing. But that's not really the problem. The big problem is the building's not settling evenly. So the corner of it is two feet over the street now. I've been told that if you drop a marble on the floor of one of the condos, it'll roll. It is still safe to live in. There have been any number of structural engineers who've crawled all over the thing,
如果你把底板做得足够大，并把它埋得足够深，你可能会遇到一点压实沉降。你的建筑可能会发生少许沉降和下沉，但不会太严重。这里有许多建筑都采用了这种方法。我的录音刚才有一秒钟变得有点听不清了，但你错过的是杰米在说千禧大厦就采用了这种混凝土筏式基础。他们的结构工程师估计，在最坏的情况下，它会下沉大约两英寸。
hired by the developer, by the owners of the condominiums, by the city. And it's safe. As long as they continue to say that, I think people will still live there because they paid an awful lot for those condos, probably can't sell them for a whole lot. And the lawsuits are just flying all over the place. One explanation they came up with is the whole problem is because of the foundation that was dug across the street from them for the Salesforce tower. Caused some movement of the subsurface soil that created the problem. Who knows? It's not all figured out yet.
现在我们已经下沉了 18 英寸，而且还在继续增加。但这其实并不是最大的问题。最大的问题是建筑并没有均匀下沉。所以它的一角现在已经向街道方向偏离了两英尺。有人告诉我，如果你在一间公寓的木地板上扔一颗大理石，它会自己滚起来。这里居住仍然是安全的。曾有无数的结构工程师对这栋楼进行了地毯式的仔细检查，
All I do know is that they've spent $130 million trying to fix the problem, putting in additional piers at the corner that is leaning the wrong way. And I guess their hope was that the building is going to settle a little bit more and maybe it'll settle away from from the corner and kind of even out over time. And you know, so far it seems to be working. The corner away from the intersection has settled more. The only problem is, and they've got all kinds of sensors in the building now. I mean, they're monitoring what's happening to the nearest millimeter, I'm sure. But apparently, it appears that the core of the building is sinking a little faster than the exterior.
他们是由开发商、公寓业主以及市政府聘请的。它是安全的。只要他们一直这么说，我想人们还是会住在那里，因为他们为这些公寓支付了极高的价格，而且现在可能很难以高价转手。各种诉讼案更是满天飞。他们提出的其中一种解释是，整个问题完全是由在他们街对面为 Salesforce 大厦挖掘的地基引起的。这导致了地下土壤的一些移动，从而造成了这个问题。谁知道呢？目前还没有完全弄清楚。
That might be hard to fix. Yeah. So we're going to leave Jamie and the downtown area and travel west to what is really my favorite spot in the city. And we can't leave San Francisco without mentioning the greatest piece of human-made infrastructure ever created. That's after this.
我所知道的是，他们已经花费了 1.3 亿美元试图解决这个问题，在那个倾斜方向错误的角落增设了桩基。我猜他们的希望是建筑会再下沉一点，也许它会从那个角落反方向沉降，随着时间推移能逐渐趋于平稳。你知道的，到目前为止似乎还真起作用了。远离十字路口的那个角落沉降得更多了。唯一的问题是——他们现在在建筑里安装了各种各样的传感器。我的意思是，他们肯定在以毫米级的精度监测着发生的一切。但显然，建筑的内核似乎比外部下沉得稍快一些。
So, let's take a break to talk about the sponsor of today's episode, Get Your Guide. With Get Your Guide, planning becomes an experience in itself, bringing the thrill of discovery to every moment leading up to your trip. No matter where you're headed, Get Your Guide is a great tool to submerge yourself in the local culture and find hidden gems. Discover and book a wide range of tours, activities, and things to do in the US and around the world. With insights from like-minded travelers and millions of verified reviews I'm a verified review, I love Get Your Guide
这可能很难修复。好了，我们要离开杰米和市中心区，向西前往真正我最喜欢的城市景点。在我们离开旧金山之前，不得不提一下人类有史以来创造的最伟大的基础设施。广告之后回来。
you'll find the tips and insights you need to have an unforgettable experience. And you can access everything you need on their app so you can spend your vacation focusing on enjoying the moment, not taking care of logistics. So I am already a Get Your Guide fan. I use them when I travel abroad. But for this partnership, as I mentioned in the episode, I decided to take the San Francisco Architecture and Public Art tour with a couple members of my family and we had a blast. It's like a walking 99% invisible tour with a great point of view and focus. I was personally familiar with a fair amount of the material because of what I do for a
那么，我们休息一下，聊聊今天节目的赞助商 Get Your Guide。有了 Get Your Guide，规划行程本身就变成了一种体验，它将探索的惊险与刺激带到了你旅程开始前的每一个瞬间。无论你前往何处，Get Your Guide 都是让你沉浸在当地文化并发现隐藏宝藏的绝佳工具。发现并预订美国及世界各地的各种旅游项目、活动和好去处。借助志同道合的旅行者的真知灼见以及数百万条真实评价——我就是真实评价的贡献者，我太爱 Get Your Guide 了——
living, but I learned a ton more. It was so much fun. Even if you are from the Bay Area, you should go on this tour. Wear like a 99 PI t-shirt and make a friend. Discover and book experiences for your next trip at GetYourGuide.com. That's GetYourGuide.com. That's GetYourGuide.com. So on my way to our next stop on tour, I came across one of my favorite San Francisco stories about
你将找到获得难忘体验所需的提示和见解。你可以在他们的应用程序上获取所需的一切，这样你就可以把假期花在享受当下上，而不是处理后勤琐事。所以我已经是 Get Your Guide 的粉丝了。我出国旅行时就会使用他们。但正如我在节目中提到的，为了这次合作，我和几位家人一起参加了旧金山建筑与公共艺术之旅，我们玩得超级开心。这就像是一场带有绝佳视角和焦点的步行版《99% Invisible》导览。因为我的职业原因，我对其中的相当一部分内容个人本就有所了解，但我还是学到了大量新知识。太有趣了。即使你是湾区本地人，你也应该去参加这个旅行团。穿上一件 99 PI 的 T 恤，去结交一个新朋友吧。访问 GetYourGuide.com，发现并预订你下一趟旅程的体验。网址是 GetYourGuide.com。网址是 GetYourGuide.com。所以在前往我们行程下一站的路上，我偶然遇到了我最喜欢的关于旧金山的另一个故事，
This gas station on Van Ness Avenue in almost every respect. It's a normal Chevron station It has a blue awning. It has a red and blue Chevron logo on the sign, but the sign and the awning don't say Chevron they say standard as in Standard oil the massive oil monopoly broken up in the early 20th century by the Sherman Antitrust Act. One of the independent companies created from that breakup was Chevron and for some reason even though this gas station is a modern Chevron station in every way it is called standard. If you call the station, they will answer the phone saying,
关于范尼斯大道（Van Ness Avenue）上的这家加油站。在几乎所有方面，它都是一家普通的雪佛龙（Chevron）加油站。它有蓝色的遮阳篷。它的招牌上有红蓝相间的雪佛龙标志，但招牌和遮阳篷上写的却不是 Chevron，而是 Standard，也就是 Standard oil（标准石油）——那个在 20 世纪初被《谢尔曼反托拉斯法》拆分的庞大石油垄断巨头。拆分后产生的独立公司之一就是雪佛龙，出于某种原因，尽管这家加油站从各方面看都是一家现代化的雪佛龙加油站，但它却被称为 Standard。如果你打电话给这家加油站，他们接电话时会说：
Chevron, and the attendant cannot say why it says standard on the sign. I have actually tried that. But I talked with a trademark lawyer named Amanda Lewandowski and she helped me uncover the mystery of the seemingly anachronistic gas station. So a trademark can be any word, name, symbol, or device used by someone who has bona fide intent to use the mark in commerce and that they're using that word, symbol, or device
“雪佛龙”，而且工作人员也说不出为什么招牌上会写着 Standard。我实际上尝试过。但我采访了一位名叫阿曼达·莱万多夫斯基（Amanda Lewandowski）的商标律师，她帮我揭开了这个看似不合时宜的加油站背后的谜团。因此，商标可以是任何单词、名称、符号或装置，由具有真实意图将该商标用于商业活动的人使用，并且他们正在使用该单词、符号或装置
to identify the source of their goods and services. The phrase bona fide intent means that if you want to keep the trademark, you have to legitimately use it. So in this particular case, when Standard Oil was busted up, the Standard Oil trademark retained a lot of goodwill and value. And if whatever reason down the line, Chevron wants to take advantage of that value,
来识别其商品和服务的来源。“真实意图”一词意味着，如果你想保留该商标，你就必须合法地使用它。所以在这种特定情况下，当标准石油被拆分时，标准石油的商标保留了大量的商誉和价值。如果由于某种原因，日后雪佛龙想要利用这份价值，
they have to use the name Standard somewhere. You can't just put on some pamphlet or something disingenuous. Like you have to really use it. So they have to prominently use the Standard name in conjunction with oil and gas services if they want to keep it. So that's why there's a standard gas station that for all intents and purposes operates as a Chevron station in San Francisco and in 15 other
他们就必须在某个地方使用 Standard 这个名字。你不能只把它印在某些小册子或诸如此类不真诚的东西上。你必须真正地使用它。因此，如果他们想保留这个名字，就必须在与石油和天然气服务相关的场合突出使用 Standard 这个名称。这就是为什么在旧金山以及美国的其他 15 个
locations in the US. So about three miles southwest of this gas station is legitimately like my favorite spot inside of San Francisco. When people visit I always send them there even though there's nothing actually there or a big part of what was there is missing. So let's head to Mount Olympus. So we are at the very top of Upper Terrace Road, on a hill that was once thought to be the geographic center of the city. It is very windy, but the view is just amazing. It's a 360 degree panorama of the best views of the city.
地方，会存在一家实际上以雪佛龙加油站方式运营的 Standard 加油站。所以在距离这座加油站西南约三英里处，有一个绝对算得上是我在旧金山最喜欢的地方。每当有人来访，我总是把他们送到那里，尽管那里实际上什么都没有，或者说曾经在那里的大部分东西都已经不见了。所以让我们前往奥林匹斯山（Mount Olympus）。我们现在位于上露台路（Upper Terrace Road）的顶端，在一座曾被认为是该市地理中心的小山上。这里风非常大，但视野简直太棒了。这是一个 360 度的全景视角，能将这座城市最佳的风景尽收眼底。
At the top of the stairs here, there's a tiny hilltop park and a raised plinth and a massive stone pedestal that rises to nothing. It was once the base of a 12 foot bronze statue. The statue was called Triumph of Light. It was a robed woman that looked a little like the Statue of Liberty and she was holding aloft a giant torch in one hand and in her other hand she had a piece of parchment. And below her, at her feet, was a crouched figure sort of reaching up to these two objects as if symbolizing mankind reaching for light and knowledge.
这里的阶梯顶部，有一个极小山顶公园、一个高出地面的底座，以及一个直插云霄、上面却空空如也的宏伟石质基座。它曾经是一座 12 英尺高的青铜雕像的底座。这座雕像被称为《光明的胜利》（Triumph of Light）。那是一个穿着长袍的女人，看起来有点像自由女神像，她一只手高举着一支巨大的火炬，另一只手拿着一张羊皮纸。在她下方、她的脚边，是一个蜷缩着的人物，正伸手够向这两样东西，仿佛象征着人类对光明与知识的渴求。
It was erected in 1887 by then developer and future mayor Adolf Sutro as a symbol of liberty and progressivism. When Sutro dedicated the statue in 1887 on Thanksgiving Day, he told the crowd, May the light shine from the torch of the goddess of liberty to inspire our citizens to good and noble deeds for the benefit of mankind. At that moment, it must have seemed like it would stand forever to be a timeless reminder of the importance of liberty and civilization and philanthropy. But it didn't last.
它由当时的开发商、后来的市长阿道夫·苏特罗（Adolf Sutro）于 1887 年竖立，作为自由和进步主义的象征。1887 年感恩节那天，苏特罗为这座雕像落成剪彩时，他向人群说道：“愿自由女神火炬的光芒闪耀，激励我们的公民为了人类的福祉做出善良而崇高的行为。”在那一刻，它看起来必定会永远屹立，成为提醒人们重视自由、文明和慈善事业的永恒标志。但它并没有持续下去。
In the late 1930s, people were already referring to it as the Mystery Monument, which strikes me as a shockingly brief period of time to have forgotten about Sutro's statue and its lofty ideals. By the 1940s there was discussion about removing it because pieces had fallen off. And after decades of neglect, sometime in the 1950s, it just disappears. No one knows who ordered its removal or what happened to the statue. All that is left is the stone base, a lovely landscaped knoll, and a view that sends hikers and dog walkers up here regularly, even though
在 20 世纪 30 年代末，人们已经开始把它称为“神秘纪念碑”（Mystery Monument），这在我看来，人们把苏特罗的雕像及其崇高的理想忘得精光，所花费的时间短得令人震惊。到了 40 年代，由于部分雕像已经脱落，人们开始讨论将其拆除。经过几十年的忽视，大约在 20 世纪 50 年代的某个时候，它就这样消失了。没有人知道是谁下令拆除的，也不知道雕像究竟遭遇了什么。留下的只有石质底座、一片风景优美的小丘，以及依然吸引着徒步旅行者和遛狗者定期登顶的壮丽景色，尽管
there is no statue to admire. There's not even a plaque. I know I don't want them to replace the statue. The location of the story is kind of perfect as it is, but it would be cool to have a picture and description of what was once here for people to read. Or maybe not, I don't know. Maybe it's better as a mystery. But I truly love this place. It's the greatest. So I would be remiss if I didn't take you to the greatest piece of infrastructure ever
已经没有了供人赞叹的雕像。甚至连一块牌匾都没有。我知道我不希望他们重建这座雕像。故事的这个地点就现状而言可以说是完美的，但如果能有一张照片和对这里曾经存在过的事物的描述供人们阅读，那倒也不错。或者也许不要，我不知道。也许作为一个未解之谜更好。但我真的非常喜欢这个地方。它太棒了。所以如果我不带你们去人类创造的
created and that is the Golden Gate Bridge. So I'm looking up at the bridge from Cavallo Point, which is not actually in this city. It's on the north side of the bridge, but it's a great place to take in the majesty of this beautiful thing. Earlier I mentioned that the Transamerica pyramid works better, you know, the farther you are away from it and that the Salesforce tower is better up close. Well, the Golden Gate Bridge is perfect from every angle and vantage point. Its slender silhouette is elegant as seen from the East Bay. It is a joy to drive over it. It is a joy to walk over it. My favorite snapshot view of the bridge is when you're driving south on 101 and you see it framed in the arch of the Robin Williams tunnel. I never tire of it.
最伟大的基础设施，我就会严重失职，那就是金门大桥（Golden Gate Bridge）。我现在正从卡瓦洛角（Cavallo Point）抬头仰望这座大桥，卡瓦洛 Point 实际上并不在这座城市里。它位于大桥的北侧，但这里是领略这一美丽事物宏伟气势的绝佳地点。我之前提到过，泛美金字塔越远看效果越好，而 Salesforce 大厦近看更佳。嗯，金门大桥从任何角度和观赏点看都是完美的。从东湾望去，它纤细的轮廓优雅迷人。开车驶过它是一种享受。步行走过它也是一种享受。我最喜欢的关于大桥的快照视角是，当你开车向南行驶在 101 号公路时，看到它被罗宾·威廉姆斯隧道（Robin Williams tunnel）的拱门完美框住。我永远看不够它。
It is just a gorgeous thing. So I'm down at the shoreline of Cavallo Point, this other perfect view of the bridge, so I can stand and talk about it for a little bit. The chief engineer in the construction of the bridge was Joseph Strauss, but a lot of the structural design was by a fellow named Charles Alden Ellis. They fought a lot while the bridge was being built, with Strauss accusing Ellis of wasting time and money. But Strauss was the boss, and he fired Ellis and ended up getting most of the credit for the bridge himself. Ellis only got recognition for his contribution decades later. And you might think this Joseph Strauss seems like a credit-hogging nasty piece
它简直是一件精美绝伦的艺术品。现在我来到了卡瓦洛点的海岸边，这里拥有大桥的另一个完美视角，我可以站在这里稍微聊聊它。大桥建设的首席工程师是约瑟夫·斯特劳斯（Joseph Strauss），但大部分结构设计是由一位名叫查尔斯·奥尔登·艾利斯（Charles Alden Ellis）的人完成的。在大桥建造期间，他们经常争吵，斯特劳斯指责艾利斯浪费时间和金钱。但斯特劳斯是老板，他解雇了艾利斯，并最终将大桥的大部分功劳揽在了自己身上。艾利斯直到几十年后才获得认可。你可能会觉得这个约瑟夫·斯特劳斯看起来是个爱抢功劳、令人讨厌的
of work. And that may be true. But there is much more to him than that. Chief engineer Joseph Strauss was maniacally devoted to worker safety. The job of bridgeman was very dangerous. 60 mile an hour gusts of wind could come out of nowhere and sweep men into the water. So it made a rule that all workers had to wear clip-on safety lines. And a lot of the macho tough guys wouldn't wear them and complained. But on the Golden Gate Bridge build, if you didn't wear one, you were fired. And eventually everyone fell in line.
家伙。这或许是真的。但他的远不止于此。首席工程师约瑟夫·斯特劳斯对工人的安全有着近乎狂热的执着。桥梁工人的工作非常危险。时速 60 英里的阵风会毫无征兆地袭来，将工人卷入水中。因此他制定了一条规则：所有工人都必须佩戴夹扣式安全绳。许多大男子主义的硬汉不愿意佩戴并抱怨连天。但在金门大桥的建设过程中，如果你不戴安全绳，你就会被解雇。最终所有人都服从了规定。
He was also one of the first chief engineers to insist on hard hats on the job. But the ultimate expression of his commitment to worker safety was when he spent over $130,000 on a safety net to be installed as work began on the bridge's roadbed. It was the most expensive, elaborate safety device ever conceived for a major construction site. The net ended up saving 19 lives. 19 men fell off the bridge during construction and fell safely into the net. It spanned across the entire length of the bridge and stuck out about 10 feet wider than the roadbed on each side because with those winds, people didn't just fall straight down. They flew some distance and the net caught them all.
他也是最早坚持在工地上佩戴安全帽的首席工程师之一。但他对工人安全的承诺的终极体现，是他在大桥路面开工时花费了 13.0 万多美元安装了一张安全网。这是为大型建筑工地构思的最昂贵、最复杂的安全装置。这张网最终挽救了 19 条生命。有 19 名工人在施工期间从大桥上失足跌落，并安全地落在了网上。它横跨大桥的全长，并且在两侧比路面突出了大约 10 英尺，因为伴随着那些强风，人们不仅仅是笔直往下掉。他们会飞出一段距离，而安全网把他们全都接住了。
The 19 men who accidentally fell into the net called themselves the halfway to hell club, which is pretty badass. The net became this real morale booster. Workers were kind of excited by the notion that people actually cared and the net turned out to be kind of fun, so much so that they had to be ordered not to jump into the net on purpose. There was a major accident during construction where 10 men died and a platform broke free and crushed the bridgemen below. But even with that one-off event, the safety record of the Golden Gate bridge construction was far better than that of the Oakland Bay Bridge where 28 workers died.
那 19 个意外跌入网中的人自称为“半道下地狱俱乐部”（Halfway to Hell Club），这真是酷毙了。这张网真正起到了提振士气的作用。工人们对“居然有人真的在乎他们”这种观念感到有点兴奋，而且这张网结果证明还挺好玩的，以至于他们不得不被勒令禁止故意跳进网里。在施工期间曾发生过一起重大事故，有 10 名工人丧生，当时一个平台断裂，砸中了下方的桥梁工人。但即便有这样一次突发事件，金门大桥施工的安全记录也远比奥克兰海湾大桥（Oakland Bay Bridge，那场事故导致 28 名工人丧生）要好得多。
The Golden Gate Bridge was a real leap forward in valuing the lives of bridgemen and iron workers. And that's what I think of when I see it now. That the greatest human-made structure was made humanely. After the completion of the Golden Gate Bridge, Joseph Strauss returned to his first passion, which was poetry, his most famous poem being The Mighty Task is Done, and it goes, At last the mighty task is done, resplendent in the western sun. The bridge looms mountain high, its tightened piers grip ocean floor, its great steel arms
金门大桥在重视桥梁工人和钢铁工人的生命方面实现了真正的飞跃。这就是现在我看到它时所想到的。人类创造的最伟大建筑，是在充满人性的关怀下建造的。金门大桥完工后，约瑟夫·斯特劳斯回归了他的初心——诗歌，他最著名的诗作是《伟大的任务已经完成》（The Mighty Task is Done），其中写道：“伟大的任务终于完成，在西斜的太阳下熠熠生辉。大桥如山般高耸，紧绷的桥墩紧抓着洋底，钢铁的巨臂
link shore to shore, its towers pierce the sky. It goes on from there. I think he was a better bridge builder than a poet, but I really love that he was both. Strauss died in Los Angeles at the age of 68, one year after the completion of the Golden Gate Bridge. If you ever come here, don't miss it. Walk across it, drive across it, look at it from every angle you can. This bonus episode of 99% of his book was produced by me, Roman Mars. Mixed by Martin Gonzalez. Music by Swan Riau.
连接着彼岸与此岸，高塔刺破了天空。”后面还有很多。我认为他是个比诗人更好的造桥专家，但我真的很喜欢他兼具这两种身份。斯特劳斯在洛杉矶去世，享年 68 岁，正值金门大桥完工一年后。如果你有机会来这里，千万不要错过。走过它，开车过桥，从你能找到的每一个角度去欣赏它。这期《99% Invisible》的特别赞助节目由我——罗曼·马斯制作。马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）混音。音乐由天鹅里奥（Swan Riau）创作。
Special thanks to Jamie Lasher, Dara Mahali, and Sean Mahali of Ignite Tours. You can do the exact same tour that I did with Jamie by going to GetYourGuide.com and searching for the San Francisco Downtown Architecture and Public Art Tour. Jamie was so great. It was so much fun to spend time with him. My family had a fantastic time. You should do it. Our executive producer is Cathy too. Our senior editor is Delaney Hall. Our digital director is Kurt Kohlstedt. The rest of the team includes Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Kelly Prime, Chris Berube, Christopher Johnson, Vivian
特别感谢 Ignite Tours 的杰米·拉舍、达拉·马哈利（Dara Mahali）和肖恩·马哈利（Sean Mahali）。你完全可以访问 GetYourGuide.com 并搜索旧金山市中心建筑与公共艺术之旅（San Francisco Downtown Architecture and Public Art Tour），来体验我和杰米参加的同款旅行团。杰米太棒了。和他在一起度过的时光非常有趣。我的家人度过了一段美妙的时光。你们也应该去体验一下。我们的执行制片人是凯茜·图（Cathy Tu）。我们的高级编辑是德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）。我们的数字总监是库尔特·科尔施泰特（Kurt Kohlstedt）。团队的其他成员包括杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）、克里斯·贝鲁比（Chris Berube）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、维维安·
Lay, Lashma Dawn, Jacob Medina Gleason, and Joe Rosenberg. The 99% of the logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on Blue Sky as well as your own Discord server. There's a link to those as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Thank you again to the sponsor of today's episode, Get Your Guide. No matter where you're headed,
莱（Vivian Lay）、拉什马·唐（Lashma Dawn）、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森（Jacob Medina Gleason）和乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）。《99% Invisible》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）设计。我们是 SiriusXM 播客家族的一员，总部现在位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城区的潘多拉大厦向北六个街区处。你可以在 Blue Sky 以及你自己的 Discord 服务器上找到我们。在 99PI.org 上有指向这些链接以及《99PI》每一期往期节目的链接。再次感谢今天节目的赞助商 Get Your Guide。无论你前往何处，
Get Your Guide is the perfect planning tool for your next trip. Get Your Guide offers curated tours and locally vetted experiences that reveal the lesser-known aspects of cities, history, and culture. Connect with your destination through their expertly curated experiences. Choose from over 150,000 experiences including guided tours, sightseeing excursions, adventure activities, museum tickets, and more. With flexible booking options, mobile tickets,
Get Your Guide 都是你下一次旅行的完美规划工具。Get Your Guide 提供精选的旅行团和经过当地实地检验的体验，带你领略城市、历史和文化中鲜为人知的一面。通过他们精心策划的体验与你的目的地建立深厚连接。从 15,000 多种体验中进行选择，包括导游讲解团、观光游览、探险活动、博物馆门票等。凭借灵活的预订选项、手机电子票，
and millions of verified reviews, you'll find everything you need to simplify trip planning and book the best things to do in thousands of destinations worldwide. From must-see iconic attractions to unexpected under-the-radar gems, Get Your Guide has something for everyone to uncover the invisible details that shape our world. So why wait for the excitement to begin when you can feel it right now with Get Your Guide. Discover and book experiences for your next trip at GetYourGuide.com. That's GetYourGuide.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及数百万条真实评价，你将找到简化行程规划所需的一切，并在全球数千个目的地预订最佳玩乐项目。从必看的标志性景点到意想不到的冷门宝藏，Get Your Guide 为每个人提供了探索塑造我们世界的那些隐秘细节的机会。所以，为什么还要等到兴奋感开始时才去体验，你现在就可以通过 Get Your Guide 感受到它。访问 GetYourGuide.com，发现并预订你下一趟旅程的体验。网址是 GetYourGuide.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。